lá a gente eu a carta que eu falei para
vocês foi escrita em maio de 2011 por
mim um ano antes da morte da minha filha
laura
alguns dias eu desejei pela primeira vez
que ela não crescesse que ela ficasse
criança para sempre enquanto vivesse que
sua inocência e manifestado na sua forma
de agir de ser de falar de se alegrar
nunca desce lugar a consciência do mundo
egoísmo meu querer esse privilégio não
permitindo a própria ana crescer e ter
um dia essa mesma alegria e goes no meu
querer manter esse brinquedo por mais
tempo que a natureza permite
ela tem quase três anos ea uma criança
saudável alegre
astuta curiosa em amada pelos pais
cláudia e eu e ainda algo ciumenta do
irmão artur que em quatro meses completa
um ano
adora desenhar dentre muitas outras
coisas
sensação esquisita essa nunca desejei
ter filhos exatamente pela
responsabilidade que sei que viria bem
tive erros e foi a melhor coisa que já
me correu deu entretanto preocupado e
tem um pesadelo sempre que fico sabendo
da história de histórias tristes sobre
outras crianças
aí volta para casa ea vejo basta pra eu
me esquecer do mundo de meus problemas
de saúde algo debilitada mas a mera
existência arthur me transmite o alívio
de que o amor pode ser dividido e se
tornar menos tóxico direcionado a ano
essa carta não tem começo não tem enredo
não tem começo nem fim e apenas o
testemunho de um pai apaixonado
quando escrevo essa carta não tinha
idéia do presságio que ela tinha aquela
pontinha eu não tinha idéia que ela que
eu não queria entregar essa carta para
minha filha que ela ia descansar dentro
de um livro
tudo começou em junho de 2008 e junho de
2008 nasceu eu morri na minha primeira
vida e eu nasci de novo
quem tem filho sabe o que é isso
e ainda me mostrou que o amor aquele
amor
quem tem filho conhece o amor
incondicional
o amor sem limites claro é um homem
bastante antes mas eu não tinha assim eu
não conhecia o que era um amor na sua
plenitude não é
eu tenho uma carreira profissional
bastante boa e eu fui do mercado
financeiro eu consegui independência
financeira
casei com uma pessoa maravilhosa linda
inteligente simpática claudia
nós decidimos ter filhos tivemos a ama e
dois anos e meio depois tivemos o artur
e eu decidi que eu ia eu pude e portanto
iria parar de trabalhar com fins
financeiros iria me dedicar a coisas que
eu gostava muito bom e eu fiz isso em
abril de 2012
eu tive um mês um mês depois ela foi
embora
aí eu chorei muito fazia muitos anos
naquela época eu não chorar muitos anos
e me lembro ter chorado quando era
criança e depois nunca mais
tudo que eu chorei durante esses anos
nos flor e nesse ano e cláudia são
judeus na nossa religião diz que se você
quiser elevar a alma de uma pessoa que
se foi você tem que fazer coisas boas em
homenagem a ela
nós tínhamos naquele mesmo ano uma
viagem para israel
nós decidimos mantê lá porquê porque
israel talvez se não talvez um país mais
espiritualizado pudesse nos trazer algum
conforto que nós estamos buscando
desesperadamente
nós fomos mas quando nós fomos para lá
nós visitamos uma associação que nós
tínhamos conhecido há alguns anos antes
chamada araújos community center centro
comunitário árabe judaico que elas são
que existe em israel e tem como objetivo
a convivência entre os diferentes povos
de diferentes religiões que existem lá
que é uma iniciativa cada vez mais
necessária em cada vez menos oferecido
durante esse tempo que eles vieram ao
brasil antes da nossa visita à nossa
filha brincou era um coro de
adolescentes ela brincou se divertir o
ano adorava brincar e quando nós fomos
lá o presidente da associação e brian
bush nos mostrou um brinquedo acessível
eu nunca tinha vindo a cláudia não ea
claudia me fez uma pergunta será que
existem brinquedos acessíveis no brasil
logo que eu voltei ao brasil eu procurei
a prefeitura de são paulo eu procurei a
aacd e algumas outras instituições
eu me dei conta que parques para
crianças deficientes ou não existem ou
os poucos brinquedos que existem ou são
mal mantidos ou simplesmente estão fora
de ação com o seu não funcionam
claro às vezes um brinquedo novo que
depois de um ano e meio deixa não tem
manutenção e deixa de ser usado
assim nasceu nosso projeto projeto ana
laura parques para todos nós decidimos
criar lo
nós decidimos a começar do zero uma
iniciativa que nós sabíamos que tinha
muita demanda e muito pouca oferta uno
da eficiência é um do difícil porque é
um mundo difícil porque quem se envolve
nele são os pais de crianças deficientes
são profissionais e você pára por aí são
muito poucas as pessoas que querem
ajudar esse mundo porque não é um duo
fácil mundo difícil
o sorriso de uma criança deficiente vale
tanto vale mais do que o sorriso de uma
criança normal mas é difícil você chegar
nesse nesse nesse sorriso
nós decidimos também que nós iríamos
financiar esses parques é o nosso
presente a ana e seria o presente da ana
aquelas crianças que precisassem desses
parques
nós reunimos o melhor time que nós
conseguimos reunir eu fui buscar
melhorar arquiteta paisagista que
encontrei o melhor fabricante de
brinquedos que encontrei o melhor
engenheiro o melhor advogado para nos
ajudar com
a ong um artista para nos ajudar com
logo com várias outras coisas que eu
consegui reunir uma equipe de
primeiríssima linha e que nenhum momento
se negou a ajudar e até hoje nos ajuda
sim cobrar um tostão ou seja é errado
dizer que somos nós que financiamos o
projeto somos nós e todos os nossos
parceiros que não ganham dinheiro com o
projeto
nós decidimos que nós temos três
objetivos o primeiro a socialização da
criança portanto os nossos parques são
feitos para crianças com deficiência
brincarem com crianças sem deficiência e
ser repensado dessa forma ele é criado
entrega dessa forma terapia terapia é
muito importante a criança sem
deficiência faz terapia normalmente mas
não faz terapia ao ar livre um parque
isso é uma que faz uma diferença enorme
e obviamente o lazer à criança com
deficiência têm tanto direito ao lazer
quanto uma criança sem deficiência e
normalmente os pais dessas crianças
quando não tem a opção de levar um para
quando essa criança não pode brincar não
levo deixou em casa vão uma vez a um
parto normal com seu o irmão normal ou
com a criança com deficiência não brinca
fica só olhando com vontade de brincar e
portanto amanhã o pai deixou de levar
nós decidimos que o nosso projeto seria
uma plataforma aberta o que quer dizer
isso a concorrência bem vinda
quem quiser copiar os nossos parques cup
quem quiser copiar os nossos brinquedos
cup
quem quiser usar todos o novo alta
tecnologia que nós criamos cup não irá
pagar um tostão
esse é o nosso projeto a concorrência
mesmo aquela desleal é bem vinda
nós decidimos que nós vamos criar com
nossos recursos quatro parques por ano
porque porque nossos recursos são
limitados e eu tenho eu sou uma pessoa
muito cuidadosa com recurso financeiro
nos vídeos que seriam seria capaz de
arcar com altos para 44 pontos mas eu
tenho muitos amigos muitos amigos vieram
a mim dizendo eu quero doar o seu
projeto eu falei nós não aceitamos
doações
mas houve muitos pedidos empenho nós
criamos uma segunda vertente para esse
projeto com essa segunda vertente
quem quiser construir um parque e tiver
recursos
eu vou ajudar com tudo que eu toda
tecnologia com tudo o que eu aprendi
mesmo com os projetos de brinquedos com
o projeto de parques e não vou cobrar
por isso
com uma condição que exista uma placa
com o nome da minha filha vou falar um
pouco dos brinquedos
nós os brinquedos existem brinquedos
para crianças com deficiência no mundo
nós pegamos alguns desses brinquedos e
melhoramos
assim como nós criamos brinquedos que
nunca existiram e que tem se mostrado
muito bem sucedidos o banco caffagni oto
e não existe não existia antes foi uma
invenção nossa obviamente do do
fabricante de brinquedos com a ajuda de
terapeutas de várias associações com a
ajuda da arquiteta me ajuda também e
hoje um grande sucesso as crianças
adoram esse brinquedo existem obviamente
balanços também pra pra criança
deficiente que já existiam apenas
melhoramos
nós tivemos três ou quatro modelos
diferentes até nós chegarmos num modelo
que nós gostássemos a mesma coisa o
escorregador e vários outros brinquedos
além dos brinquedos um parque segundo a
nossa visão deve ter outros equipamentos
como rampas para um cadeirante brincar
pisos táteis eventualmente por uma
criança com deficiência visual o mesmo
para qualquer criança sentir uma bolinha
de gude um piso diferente nos pés é
bancos e portanto os nossos projetos não
se não só apenas um brinquedo ou dez
brinquedos é um projeto tudo para a
criança se divertir
nós definimos quais as condições para a
doação
o primeiro é a associação se compromete
com a manutenção do parque isso para nós
é muito importante porque nós esperamos
que o donatário se responsabilize pelo
parque e foi a forma que nós encontramos
fazê lo entretanto se nós fossemos arcar
com a manutenção também não teria
dinheiro pra isso porque com o nosso
objetivo de quatro partes por ano depois
de cinco dez anos já não teria recursos
para fazer a manutenção desses parques
nós decidimos também queríamos criar um
parque piloto e aprender nesse parque
piloto por três meses
de fato nós aprendemos a um ano com ele
não foi preciso um ano para nós
verificarmos aquilo que estava certo
declarou errado
nós inauguramos nesse primeiro parque no
aniversário de são paulo no ano passado
de 2014 25 de janeiro e durante todo
esse tempo durante um ano
nós verificamos tudo que estava bem
feito tudo o que precisa ser melhorado
condições dos brinquedos segurança dos
parques e houve muitos problemas
nós fizemos por exemplo um uma cama
elástica que parecia um brinquedo
excelente de fato as crianças adoram e é
ótima para terapia entretanto dá muito
problema de manutenção então nós não
vamos repeti la
da mesma forma vários outros brinquedos
deram alguns problemas de manutenção nós
melhoramos alguns nós substituímos
criamos novos brinquedos e portanto isso
demanda de nós uma vigilância constante
certamente irá demandar porque nós
continuamos criando parques ea cada novo
parque que nós criamos e e e doamos nós
aprendemos coisas novas com o projeto
rádio televisão publicações revistas
blogs todo mundo veio me procurar nós
não procurávamos publicidade nós não
precisamos de publicidade
nós não vendemos nada nós não levantamos
recurso mas e eram e com essa
publicidade muita a associação muitas
prefeituras vieram nos procurar com a
demanda que nós já sabíamos que era
grande mas a enorme de fato e toda
semana nós recebemos 23 contatos pedindo
um parque para associação para sua
cidade desde o acre até o interior de
são paulo nordeste sul todos os lugares
que fique que se informasse pelo nosso
projeto nos procuram e pedem
a então não foi difícil nós escolhemos
nosso segundo park nós doamos um segundo
parque março deste ano em araraquara que
a cidade hoje minha esposa nasceu e onde
minha filha brincou bastante a uma pai
que solicitou o o o parque há há há uma
parte muito bem feita aqui que serve
muitas crianças e também doamos um
segundo parque para a prefeitura de são
paulo
o terceiro parque me perdoe nesse
terceiro esse terceiro parque para nós é
uma é uma experiência a nova porque
porque os outros dois parques tinham
sido doados a instituições uma
instituição para um som fica mais fácil
manutenção
a prefeitura a gente sabe que não é tão
simples porque mudando o governo talvez
a qualidade da manutenção a aap ore
de toda forma nós inauguramos o parque
maio deste ano já estamos aprendendo
tremendamente com este parque
além desse projeto na hora parte para
todos nós temos alguns outros projetos
em homenagem à nossa filha
o primeiro já mencionei rapidamente um
livro que um livro pessoal que os que eu
escrevi sobre a minha filha e que é e eu
perdi uma filha e eu tentei talvez
substituir a minha filha por um filho
que eu ganhei é esse livro não é
é verdade é que ele é quase como um
filho porque eu escrevi nas minhas horas
de mais tensão de maior desgosto não é a
biblioteca nessa associação que eu
mencionei a atingir os community center
centro comunitário judaico nos decidimos
doar uma biblioteca com o nome da ana e
ela vai ser inaugurado em outubro desse
ano
todos estão convidados a e também a nós
estamos agora nos aprofundando um pouco
mais uma nova o ng para ajudar pais em
luto
nós tivemos condição de ir a um
psicólogo de eu tinha de tomar remédio
também remédio por um ano concorrendo
psiquiátrico
o luto paterna até paternal r gum texto
existe luta a terminar em todo o brasil
em todo mundo e pouca gente tem
condições de ter um sykora logo um
psiquiatra é ajudando então nosso
objetivo é ajudar aqueles que não podem
com várias vários caminhos já estamos
pensando estamos conversando com
organizações já existentes e devemos
criar as bases dessa instituição nova
este ano eu vou terminar
lendo de novo um capítulo que eu escrevi
também que eu chamo de dez mandamentos
que são os meus meus 10 mandamentos
porque a coisa mais próxima de deus a
coisa mais próxima do divino que eu
conheci foi a minha filha e hoje esses
dez mandamentos são os mandamentos que
inspiram talvez cada um que sofram algum
tipo de de trauma desse tipo possa
escrever os seus próprios fundamentos e
se inspirarem da mesma forma eu sou anna
com a filha que mostrou a vida terá os
outros filhos e servir as não chorar as
pelo meu nome lembrar que as do dia que
te deixei rezar por mim honrará seus
filhos para que tenham bons dias sob a
terra
celebrar a vida sua esposa será a única
fará subir em meu nome
testemunhar as minha vida em um livro a
vida de bastará obrigado gente